so let's call uh increasing food prices
um and other types of issues that are
driven by this central banking uh
structural failure or
complexity uh how is that
affected in relationship to something
like an external shock where we have
with the russia ukraine conflict where
it's very obvious that they're a large
wheat producer natural gas etc and
people are saying look if fertilizer
prices spike if wheat can't get out of
the region
there is the potential for uh much
higher prices in a good situation in a
bad situation literally famine in some
parts of the world um and so if the long
kind of macro structure trend is the
central bank is going to cause these
issues because
they just can't get out of their way
and then you have an external shock that
also is going to drive
food prices higher like do those two
things converge and just magnify the
problem or are they two separate
situations they're exactly the same
situation and in fact
there's monetary policy um
and this is probably deeper than we can
explore
on the show but
um
but monetary policy is the rise of the
war in ukraine as well
because effectively what you have is u.s
being able to
get free energy in oil by pressing a
button
and and russia is selling their oil
or their their
value and their labor
in stuff that it gets devalued
and so that
and so as you do that and
there's one country that has a monetary
standard of the world and can keep on
getting an advantage in trade and
energy prices is
derivative of everything else and you
have an advantage in trade
other people have a disadvantage
and so their economies suffer as a
result of the
of that
advantage and disadvantage so what china
did in in 2015 with the same thing they
realized that
that the u.s couldn't pay its bills
anymore so for a long time china was a
beneficiary of this trade they kept
labor rates high low
and if late if if the economy didn't
function really well in the united
states in other words if interest rates
went up the u.s economy would have
collapsed
and therefore
all of the buying from china would have
collapsed too and their economy would
have collapsed so it was a it was a
beneficial relationship
but but china pegged their dollar their
yuan to the to the us dollar um and you
had the
low labor rates high labor rates and
that balance all over the world has to
equal zero
so when
and and to keep interest rates low
china bought us bonds correct
but when they stopped buying us bonds in
2015 and realized u.s can't pay the back
their debts
and and they're not going to pay back
their debts so they took the money and
they kept the pig they took them took
the money and hot as they're hollowing
out the
the u.s economy
and put it into
safe haven assets rare earth minerals
real estate all over the world
they're
kind of expanding their
their footprint all over the world with
that same trade balance
um instead of putting it into us dollars
so what did the u.s dollar have to do to
stop
a depression at that time
they had to monetize their own debt and
they had to actually take their
essentially take their citizens money
um
and make the rich richer and the poor
poorer by monetizing
their debt and that that creates this
geopolitical rival
um that is getting stronger and stronger
and stronger because of that same
in balance so as everybody's pegging
there everybody's trying to find their
way to what is what is valuable and what
russia just did is said
you can print your money all you want
um my oil is more valuable than your
printed dollars
and we're gonna we're gonna price it in
something else we're gonna start pricing
it in something else now if the a lot of
people are worried okay they're gonna
price it in you on or they're and i
suspect if you just do the game theory
on this china isn't going to be the
reserve currency of the world like who
would trust that to happen in another
country having a reserve currency in the
world including china would they want
that because then they would have to run
the structural imbalance that u.s is
running
and you would port
u.s labor rates would fall a lot
china labor rates would rise
and industry would move back
back and so so that balance all over the
world has and um
and so what what you need um is a
neutral reserve asset
that as
countries do
trade with one another and labor moves
up or they have a strong industry it
moves up and it rebalances automatically
and so we don't have that today um and
and all countries are trying to
essentially
look inwards and create policies that
don't realize that we live in an
interconnected world
for their own good
and their and it's
it's driving massive chaos supply chains
chaos that is bound to get a lot worse
like that we are we're we're a long way
from done on this
so what you can expect in the macro
economic landscape is
if you look back 20 years and we think
oh we live in a really safe world
everything's every everything's great
and it seems like these iterations are
getting worse and worse and it's hard to
believe and we're sucked into the news
media over and over and over in these
events
every one of them is connected and
they're getting bigger and bigger
oscillations
and i find myself
you want to react to the events
but if you look at the
structure and what has to happen they're
going to get worse i wish i didn't have
to say that but they're gonna get a lot
worse hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time